before kathryn bigelow
tackled kriti dramas about the iraq war
the hunt for bin Laden and the Detroit
race riots
she was cranking out the best movie
about bank-robbing surfers ever made and
also the only movie about bank-robbing
surfers ever made Point Break when the
Sun is out and the surf is up the
streets of LA are hot with pride now the
ex-presidents are robbing every bank in
town and the only way to stop them is to
hit the beach and catch some waves
the FBI is going to pay me to learn to
surf cut out of the 90s ride along as a
blank faced cop falls in with a
charismatic adrenaline junkie who's
secretly committing crimes and dates a
waitress with a personal connection to
his target but the fast and furious
didn't totally rip this off because in
fast they drink her ona's were in Point
Break they drink also Coronas okay
somebody owes someone money yeah Keanu
Reeves is Johnny Utah undercover agent
and famous college athlete Johnny Utah
ohio state buckeyes all-conference
remember wait what that's like sending
Tim Tebow to bust a gang of roller
bladers which I would also be totally in
to watch Reeves move on from dumb roles
like Ted Theodore Logan who would've
Joan of Arc Noah's wife to a guy who's
pretending to be dumb like Ted Theodore
Logan lifepro but also seems to be just
as dumb as Ted Theodore Logan even when
he's not undercover take your hands off
me right now okey ah no you still had so
much to learn like don't kick a dog John
wick would kill you for that bra Patrick
Swayze shines as the baddest Beast want
bank-robbing Buddha Bodhi when he and
Johnny Utah fought hard for each other
he'll kidnap the girl who gets in the
way and crank the passion to 11 as this
bromance heats up to the extreme I'm
having some people over at my house
tonight
well you're gonna ride this all the way
Johnny you and me so let's go I know
it's hard you Donny I know you want me
feel bad as I pass in your mouth hell
yeah I want you in my mouth I mean hell
yeah I wanna go surfing thrill at
supporting performances by the Red Hot
Chili Peppers the mean boss from Scrubs
Tom freakin Sizemore and a ranting
unhinged performance by Gary Busey that
we should have recognized as the cry for
help that it was I was thinking shrapnel
it tastes odd while you work wrap it in
your hands and rubbing it on your face I
wonder if any of that was even in the
script Oh
strapped in as Kathryn Bigelow shows the
boys how it's done
displaying her mastery of high stakes
high seas accurate use of surfer lingo
and for some reason a world full of
really hazy interiors I mean seriously
why is every room and Point Break full
of haze so buckle up for an adrenaline
soak thrill ride
featuring lines you'll be quoting for
decades you top gimme two I am an FBI
agent actors who overwhelm you with
charm and charisma and a premise so
stupid only the dumbest movie studio
would ever try to recreate that campy
magic again yeah I'm just gonna pretend
that never happened
starring an FBI agent Patrick Swayze
Manic Pixie Tank Girl scary Busey the
requisite angry police chief and
flip-flop dipper Danka on a surfboard
Donnie Brasco
say what you will about their music but
the Red Hot Chili Peppers have randomly
been in some of the best movies ever I
am an FBI agent you're tearing me apart
pizza don't be illegal be a seagull
The Rock eats cookies doing this voice
hurts my vocal cords I'm in real pain
stop asking me to say things for your
entertainment